Guillermo lasso no volverá a ser
candidato a la presidencia en las
elecciones anticipadas del 20 de agosto
de 2023 Finalmente hizo el anuncio en el
que aseguró que rechaza el pedido del
movimiento creó a postularse como
candidato en medio de un discurso en la
presidencia de la República rodeado de
su familia y su gabinete de gobierno
Guillermo lasso no expresó las razones
por las cuales rechaza la postulación a
la presidencia tampoco anunció Cuál será
el papel muy Movimiento Político que
lidera no informó si respaldará algún
otro candidato durante su declaración a
la prensa Guillermo lasso hizo una
advertencia a elegir entre lo que según
a su juicio serán dos modelos que
tendrán los Ecuatorianos en la papeleta
electoral según él afirmó democracia o
autoritarismo e invitó los distintos
candidatos a preguntarse si su
candidatura contribuye o alejara a la
preservación de la Democracia el anuncio
se da luego que Guillermo lasso
disolviera la asamblea nacional y la
aplicación de la figura constitucional
de la muerte Cruzada lo que constituye a
la convocatoria de elecciones
anticipadas en 90 días en Ecuador según
expresa la Norma electoral Guillermo
lasso aseguró que la aplicación de la
muerte Cruzada la realizó para frenar un
intento por tomarse la institucionalidad
del país según él firmó al mandatario
Por otra parte ya se conocen al menos
seis nombres de precandidatos que
aceptaron correr por la presidencia en
este país quien también declinó a seguir
la carrera presidencial es el líder
indígena de la unidad Isa por el
movimiento pachakuti Mientras tanto
todavía se espera conocer a quién será
el candidato de la oposición que
agrupará al corre